this is bound to be a film out dead that
pushes one or two of your buttons these
movies on the other hand push every
single one of them these movies aren't
just hard to watch they aren't just edgy
and they don't just challenge the entire
concept of good taste they're deeply
disturbing on almost every level
director Eli Roth is no stranger to
movies that are hard to sit through his
2006 horror hit hostel proved that
beyond a shadow of a doubt and turned
his name into a synonym for over-the-top
violence with the green inferno
however Roth pushes things further than
ever before and unless you're a seasoned
gore Hamm's chances are you won't make
it to the end in the grand tradition of
the video nasties of the 70s and 80s
Inferno tells the tale of the group of
college-aged activists who head to the
Amazon to protest the logging operation
they find cannibals instead we are
offered an escape tonight all of us
[Music]
you can probably imagine the nonstop
stream of gore and misery that follows
and if you can't last through the whole
movie well that's kind of the point in
an interview with Rolling Stone Roth
said if I've really done my job as a
director nobody can actually watch your
movie you don't want people walking out
of the movie you want them running out
of the theater screaming when that
happens that's like a standing ovation
for me the green inferno achieves it's
unsettling dread by shooting on location
in Peru utilizing physical special
effects and casting members of the
Amazons natives population in key roles
that's lived some critics to adduce
inferno of cultural appropriation but
Roth doesn't seem to mind he's insisted
that the amateur actors were all paid
fairly and while they didn't have much
experience in front of the camera they
quote got it right away and loved it
darn confused Martin's the 2008 French
thriller with his 2015 American remake
both movies have roughly the same plot
but there's one big difference the
english-language version is remarkably
tame
despite its inherently unsettling
subject matter that's by design writer
Mark L Smith told creative screenwriting
I'm not a lover of violence I tried to
stay away from all the violence and keep
it off screen which was kind of the
polar opposite of the original side if
you've got a low tolerance for abuse and
still want to watch something messed up
for some reason stick with that one on
the other hand if you want to test you
mettle go for the original with graphic
depictions of brutal acts martyrs isn't
for the faint of heart
when it's screened it can audiences left
the theaters in droves they just
couldn't handle it from the basic plot
to the film's horrifying climax it's
easy to understand why sure Mardas is
also a nuanced story about guilt and
friendship and Smith is right when he
says that there's more to it than mere
gore but the gore is a big part of it
like the New York Times wrote this isn't
one for amateurs you won't find
everything that makes irreversible hard
to watch on screen don't get us wrong
emotionally the movie is absolutely
brutal it's bad enough that even at Star
Monica Bellucci can't sit through it but
that's not the only reason over 250
people fled from the film's can premiere
with many fainting or seeking medical
treatment the sounds played a big role
to see irreversible uses infrasound
low-frequency sound waves to augment
it's unsettling visuals we can't
actually hear the sound but your body
registers it anyway
leading to feelings of anxiety unease
distress and depression in addition to
the shivers and sometimes nausea it's
sort of anxiety producing I don't know
about fear but it's unnerving it's a
trick that many modern horror films use
including Paranormal Activity
and while infrasound doesn't affect
every member of the audience in the same
way it's credited as one of the reasons
why irreversible makes many members of
its audience feel sick in fact many
people who
don't even make it very far into the
film thanks to the soundtrack a mere
half-hour of irreversible is more than
enough for many viewers forcing them to
turn the film off before its most
horrific action even truly begins when
the woman made its Sundance debut many
people left the theater others simply
wished they had by all indications
that's exactly the type of reaction
director Lucky McKee was hoping for the
plot which centers on the dysfunctional
families attempt to civilize a wild
woman by locking her in the basement and
torturing her is explicitly designed to
push every misogynistic and toxically
masculine button we really get to keep
her we do oddly it's also a thoughtful
and nuanced film at least once you get
past its surface shocks it's not all
gore and gloom the woman has something
to say it also has a pretty decent
Rotten Tomatoes score especially for
this kind of thing there's a rewarding
experience lurking underneath the
discomfort and chills you just have to
last through the whole movie to find
that Goodluck film go is at the Toronto
International Film Festival's should
have known what they were in for after
all it's late night Midnight Madness
programming block has its name to erase
anything goes unfortunately not everyone
got the memo and one film fan found
Coralie far JS revenge so intense that
he had a seizure right in the middle of
the theater reportedly it was a
stomach-churning scene in which a man is
forced to remove a giant piece of glass
from his foot the dinner
Vijay told indieWIRE we started to hear
someone say hello hello
from the audience I didn't know if it
was someone making a joke in the room
then I see the paramedics in the cinema
thankfully the audience member was fine
he was in good company to revenge laid
matilda lutz admitted the same made her
feel weird as well and she was there
when the same was shot if that scene
doesn't get the rest of revenge very
well my starring lots as a woman out for
vengeance after being left for dead by
her lover and his friends all of which
is shown on screen
naturally revenge is a lean brutal and
extremely well reviewed thriller this
as thrilling as it is disturbing just
don't take it lightly
lars von trier has been down this road
before
in 2009 the director rolled into ken
with Antichrist a film that probably
deserves its own entry on this list is
wildly misogynistic unsettling and is
relentlessly bleep and people walked out
when it screamed a decade later von
trier did it again after doling out a
multi-year ban to von trier after the
director said he sympathized with Adolf
Hitler can authorities decided to let
the filmmaker
exhibit his latest picture at the 2018
festivals surprise the house that Jack
built is even more difficult to stomach
than its predecessor in the movie Matt
Dillon plays a serial killer on a
12-year murder spree when the house that
Jack built screamed people left not just
one or two either reportedly more than a
hundred vegetable guests decided to
leave the theater rather than finish
watch in the aftermath attendees turned
to Twitter to express their disgust
calling von Trier's movie formative and
claiming that a quote should not have
been made their criticisms but they
should have expected it the house that
Jack built is so gross that it wasn't
even allowed to compete for the Palme
d'Or cans
top prize instead it's grained outside
of competition in order to avoid any
Antichrist like controversies when
horror fans entered the theatres as a
vibe at Fantasia fest 2015 they received
special by branded Bob Dax it wasn't a
job as Fantasia fest co-director Mitch
Davis posted on Facebook during the
screening at least two people pasta one
hit his head on the stairs
another started puking by the time the
film wrapped and ambulance was on site
treating various members of the audience
for illness that's a pretty strong
reaction but on the other hand bite is a
particularly gross movie the horror
begins in Costa Rica where a bride-to-be
receives a mysterious insect bite while
celebrating her Bachelorette
I'm fine babe not that Casey has time to
worry about it of course she's already
struggling with her upcoming wedding her
domineering soon-to-be mother-in-law and
a fiance child filled plans for the
future black box audience however Casey
doesn't realize the severity of a
situation before long she's puking up
pus laying egg sacks around her
apartment raising a hive of carnivorous
monsters and watching this her body
decomposes revealing the insectoid form
underneath
in other words spot quickly goes from a
middling character drama into a full-on
body horror and it doesn't really offer
a break once it kicks into high gear and
as Fantasia fest proves it's not an easy
movie to finish in fact you might find
to be something of an endurance test if
you do sit down to watch it when a
filmmaker says their movie is going to
make you vomit lethal it's far far
better than the alternative Sam
Peckinpah's grim and gritty Western the
Wild Bunch
might be considered a classic now but
during its initial run the movies
hardcore violence was too much for late
60s movie goers preview audiences
lambasted the film calling it wasted
insanity after launch cowboy king john
wayne complained that the Wild Bunch is
blood-soaked action quote destroyed the
myth of the Old West
even by modern standards the Wild Bunch
is still grotesquely violent in the 90s
Warner Brothers tried to release a
director's cut with 10 extra minutes of
footage
none of that news stuff was particularly
gory but the MPAA still took the
opportunity to change the Wild Bunch is
rating from an arm to an nc-17 keeping
the film out of theaters for an extra
two years the Wild Bunch is brutal and
uncompromising and at the time was too
much for many theater attendees some of
whom walked out just 20 minutes into the
film just because the Wild Bunch is a
classic doesn't mean it's easy to watch
even today all of that bloody ultra
violence means that you might have to
step away before the final credits roll
do I be ashamed you'd hardly be the
first one ain't like it used to be but
it'll do
[Music]